lundi dernier karine le marchand était
de retour sur m6 en compagnie de ses
agriculteurs adoré ont sans rater à tous
je suis très heureux d'avoir trouvé et
qui dit nouvelle saison dit nouvelles
têtes parmi ces nouveaux candidats en
quête d'amour on a découvert les six
premiers de cette aventure cinq
agriculteurs et une agricultrice
nathalie qui a ému les interviews de par
son histoire qu'a été battu oui depuis
toujours
tu sais tout jamais je me rendais pas
compte mais les téléspectateurs de la
chaîne ont également fait la
connaissance de vincent sympathique
provençal un brin trop séducteur quand
je suis à moi
chaque morceau de beurre avec les fonds
au soleil et j'avais complètement la
masse pour daniel a lui aussi beaucoup
fait parler sur les réseaux est plutôt
en bien il faut dire que ce sympathique
monsieur a séduit par son extravagance
dit m
je sais
que je t'aime
hervé le 2e vincent de l'émission se
sont aussi présentés à karine donc je me
sens aujourd'hui capable
d'entamer une
une aventure amoureuse une première
salle de portraits qui a attiré 3 12
millions téléspectateurs soit 12 à 8 6%
du public
un beau score pour une première soirée
alors l'amour est dans le pré un casting
réussi se sent capable de ludivine
j'aime cette émission au moins autant
que vous si c'était même un peu plus
dont vous sentez sincèrement que moi je
fais bien la vente
non je lui ai demandé s'il est mort ou
des combats d'amour toute façon le lundi
ne m'appelez plus 21h09 ettore torri
je suis déjà accro à ce casting est déjà
des personnages nathalie la barbie
deschamps et revend l'air
100 des bois non mais je trouve qu'il ya
des perches cent des voix mais oui parce
qu'il arrive à 10-2 face caméra que il
était plus haut qu'à raison mais vous
vous imaginez là les gens qui ont envoyé
des lettres
c'est quand même fou nous faut choisir
le monsieur qui m'est fait excuser moi
c'est des vrais gens c'est peut-être pas
des gens qu'on voit dans nos cercles
mais c'est des gens qui existe qui soit
mais je dépanne n'existe pas mais plein
de trucs de problème vous pouvez pas que
c'est toujours un peu dans la caricature
steph allez-y c'est vrai que d'année en
année et orbi quand même c'est pas pire
en pire c'est toujours les mêmes
d'accord il ya toujours effectivement un
puceau généralement il ya toujours une
profite ici chercher avant de carrément
j'aime bien cette édition très bien
j'aime bien les missions et j'ai bien
aimé nathalie je les trouvais frêche est
trouvée elle mais elle m'a ému voila
voila c j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé sympa
mais c'est vrai que les profils se
ressemblent d'amnéville soit 400 onces
et pour ce pauvre où benjamin osé trahir
et yann tainguy publiera aussi dans ses
émissions là il faut qu'à partir du
moment où on fait les réunions on fait
ce qu'il faut qu'on est ce qu'on appelle
entre guillemets des bons clients
c'est un objet tout placement avoir des
histoires fortes quelquefois même à
scénariser autour de l'histoire
appuyez forcément sur des choses comme
la rb le picard qui a jamais vu le loup
bassa océans le revenu voilà il ya la
femme nathalie qui voit la vie en rose
qui a été la victime de violences
conjugales c'est des sujets d'actualité
aussi donc forcément il faut un moment
donné ap le téléspectateur bavay une
émission a résulté d'hier et avant tout
de tout ça mais oui et je devais y est
ça le présente la société aussi je suis
désolé et enfin volaille oui à des puces
on nous on a maxime bike
[Rires]
et en bout de table sa branche r goody
avec l'occurrence et moi en l'occurrence
est une femme battue cette année moi je
trouve ça vachement bien il y en a qu à
des critères différents mais ça c'est
normal c'est comme la société regardait
ghana pas d'eux qu'ils se ressemblent
autonome et c'est ça qui est bien voilà
j'ai l'impression que plus encore
l'amour est dans le pré représente la
société